it's like you just don't know what
you're going to get well then then you
should learn to pick better but this is
like something yeah saying learn to pick
better but everyone's good at lying
everyone's good at deceiving everyone's
good at pretending to be something
they're not but also too we do not so
are women no but i'm not saying just
yeah i'm saying in both parties everyone
can like everyone can do whatever but
the problem is we don't have actual
conversations to decipher
what kind of person you're right but
we've said that we've said this multiple
times in different ways it's about core
values if you are talking to a man and
your first questions aren't about you
know your core values why why would this
progress it's true you know and i think
holding accountability for your part to
play in the suffering in a relationship
it takes two to tango as they say right
so
it's a contribution from both sides
nobody's perfect we understand that um
but at the same time you do not want to
take the victim position
because then that means that you're not
taking accountability for your part to
play in the problem but do you know what
it is
sometimes so quick thing
when there are situations where no one's
taking accountability that's why it's so
helpful to go for these like mediations
and counselling because someone on
outside can look into what you are blind
yeah but one but my point is if you
if you discern this early on you will
not have to go through all of that but
sometimes i feel people
choose that they can see something but i
choose to like turn a blind eye to it
for
for a period of time
because you know how like women
i feel like a lot of women see a man as
uh
not his purpose
potential potential yes you meet someone
to see the potential you don't meet
someone to be like oh i see you you what
am i gonna like
about you you you're sorry you know
you're just to what my point is is when
you have a conversation with this
potential
future you know your man
you have to ask questions that discern
the information you need to know if you
don't know what the man's goals are from
early on why are you here if you don't
know if the man wants a family why are
you here
if you don't understand his family
dynamic why are you here do you get me
what relationships
he already has established will show you
a lot about the type of man he is
and
i just wanted to say and with that
information you can make a decision
that will be beneficial to both parties
well and you attract what you are
so if you keep attracting toxic people
something about it is toxic
you're the only common denominator in
every single situation you're in you
can't run from yourself
um
i'm sorry can i just
say you're saying that like you have to
discern by asking what are their goals
what they're this what are they that
right people's
decisions change
things influence them and change so you
might meet someone and they might say oh
i want children by this age
they get to let's just say they say they
want children by 30.
they get to 25 and they're like actually
i want to live my life a bit more no i
don't want children so you've been with
them for five years thinking like okay
we're going to get to a stage where
we're going to have kids we're going to
do this we're going to do that and then
it changes or it might be like might be
like business goals for example and then
you might be supporting them you might
be being submissive being there for them
and then that business idea changes but
then when you when so for example i'm
saying that but i feel like the response
is going to be then you pick the wrong
man and you should have looked better
but
you got told what you got told
so what i'd say to you then is i'd go
all right
after two years have i married you have
i put an engagement ring on you or have
i told you in five years time this is
where my business is going to be and
this is when i want to start looking at
possibly being serious with you but
that's what i'm saying those those are
the things that you might ask and they
might answer correctly and you will
believe it yeah so
if i've answered correctly right let's
just say for the two years engagement i
haven't done that but i'm still talking
about i'm i'm not in financially secure
a position i haven't done the two-year
thing
are you still sticking with me for the
five-year term so you're saying that
like i'm saying there was red flags
before
that you ignored because there was other
goals that you wanted to
i said i was going to reach
and i'm saying at that moment you've
made a choice to stick with me so all
the consequences that come from that
choice
are essentially your own fault
and it's it's the red flags that you've
ignored because you've seen the
potential or the things that i've said
i'm going to do but
prior to that
there was probably on the date i said oh
yo we'll meet for eight o'clock i've
come at 10.
there was probably
the small white flags you might call
them but they were red flags from the
jump that
showed my character
and it's those things that you will
ignore because
you're seeing the potential
and also wanting to do it all over again
because that's another factor as well
speaking to them oh that's another
factor as well um having to do that all
over again imagine you're in a
three-year relationship
and then now you break up and whatnot
and you have to do that all over again
before you know it you reach 30 and then
you get and then you valued well but
that's that's because women don't date
intentionally like a lot of times we
don't from our early 20s say i'm dating
for marriage if you're not dating for
marriage like be on with it be done we
don't do that and then later when we
waste a couple years and bring it up
down the road and he doesn't put a ring
on it then we waste half our 20s and
we're confused
is really confusing
but i don't think it's confusing at all
i think men generally are pretty honest
about what they want and if they're not
their actions show pretty early what
their intentions are i think women we
just get attached and we don't listen
but would you not say
men
because you know how like they say men
are a bit more less mature than women at
a certain point so would you not say
that
from let's say
early
late teens to mid
20s they're just free balling it they're
going with whatever
the vibe is
we could choose an older guy okay an
older guy now for him he's got
he probably has things
set
he's probably he has goals like he knows
like
i want this this and this and i can't
lie like that's very attractive because
it shows that like you're
straightforward like you're not playing
about you know what you want you're
gonna get what you want but it does it
doesn't necessarily mean you've got a
time frame you just know you want that
and some women have to understand
that when a mind is when a mind is set
it's set so you're either with it or
you're not basically well i mean let's
let's let me look right now so the
average age
of first marriage
uk let's see average age of first
marriage in the uk
um
is 31.
wow so i mean like you could look at 21
you could look at guys that are 31.
that's not that that's not a bad age gap
10 years that's that's not about yeah i
like that age
what well i don't know about that age
group
i can't hear you i said
oh me and the smile hey can you hear
yourself yeah yeah yeah i can i think
you better you gotta push it yeah yeah i
can't hear myself
hold on i think the wire maybe is
stopping it from what i'm saying is five
to ten years age gap is all right
yeah that's i think that's i mean i
would do up to 20 to be honest
do you know why it's a bit difficult now
is because of this whole modernization
and how women are changing
because if a girl is now in her 20s
[Music]
depending if if culture and religion
isn't a factor that's different but if
it's not
she just wants to
see everything be everywhere like have
fun live her life because that's what's
seen
on tv that's what's seen on social media
so it's like marriage is not a thing to
them at that time
or settling down at that time together i
mean because you do have these people
that aren't relationships from 18
they're like i'll be my man for like
three four years you're thinking how old
are you like oh yeah i'm only 22. you're
thinking about um
so when are you two gonna break up and
then make up again like when i say break
up when are you gonna separate from each
other
get to
see the world do whatever and then come
back again if that makes sense because
if relationships i feel like
long-term relationships have a gap
for a little bit if that makes sense
because of how much you change
so if you don't take a break
it's just going to be a continuous cycle
and then eventually just going to blow
up and be like like you want to break up
for a little bit and then get back
together you like separate
i don't think
that's really unhealthy
saying it like that sounds wild no no
there's no way you could say that it
wouldn't sound well and i'll explain to
you why
whoever initiates the breakup right
will have an idea that you're an
expendable asset
as in like i can break up with you
and then get back with you
with no repercussions because i can call
it a break
i went through this in my first
relationship where i had no clue what
was going on like
i took a break
yeah because
my partner felt like they needed that
and i said cool that's fine
and then i learned that at that moment
like you become an expendable asset
because that person can take a break or
break up with you and get back with you
whenever they want
and then that's an emotional toll for
you
because they don't value it as an asset
they don't think they can lose you
it's only when you can say boom
we're done
we we're not getting back together and
this is done like you can see it like
that or you can see it as like
you need to separate from one another to
have an understanding that yo this is
actually the person for me because you
might have a break for four years maybe
i mean because i do the reason why i say
that is because i do see relationships
where they were dating when they were
younger they've taken a break and
they've come back together again when
they're much older and much experienced
with life and everything okay so
that's very much a woman's point of view
because like basically you're saying to
a man
let me go get ran through
let me go rack up more let me go four
years you're gonna sleep with somebody
okay if you're having sex with him
you're gonna sleep with somebody so
you're saying
let's take a break let me go acquire
more damage
let me go get more bodies and let me
come back to you later
and ask for a higher price which is a
ring no but you'll seen it
from a man's point of view you're seeing
it from a woman's point of view like ish
am i wrong
yeah
i'm not saying your point of view is
wrong i'm just saying this is your point
of view and i'm talking from a man's
point of view and so is paul
she's only telling you what men are
thinking
and essentially you as a woman
if you want to acquire a man you need to
understand what i'm thinking
maybe maybe it might not even be
important to you i don't know but like
like if you're looking to get a man then
as long you can make a decision and
that's up to you completely but
at least you have the knowledge to
understand
okay this is what i feel
but this is what he thinks this is what
men think so
so if if you've been with someone for a
while yep
and you can feel yourself like not
feeling attracted to them yeah but you
still love them
so you're going to carry on staying with
that person
i mean okay if you
because you're showing a man what is he
going to get as a wife
that's that's what you're you're
applying for so if i'm if i'm awake if
i'm dating a man and i'm applying wait
wait so if i'm dating a man i'm applying
for the position of a wife because i
wouldn't spend my time or date a guy
that i i wouldn't marry just me
personally like why why are we wasting
my time so that's the position i'm
applying for so
i'm showing him that when times get
tough and i get bored i'm gonna leave
why would a man want a wife a girl that
when she's not
happy she's just gonna leave when things
get tough because you're gonna live
until you're 90. there's going to be
years where you don't really like each
other
and so this is men's problem with modern
women they're selfish because we put our
happiness above all else
but i'm asking in the sense of
if you are with someone and you can feel
it like okay as a man you're with a
woman for a long time but you can feel
yourself
detaching yourself from her but you
still love her yeah are you still gonna
stay yeah
okay
because at that moment i'd understand
that there's more to it than just my
feelings or at that current moment in
time because if you're telling me at
that moment i'm not feeling it cool what
happens in two months time no but you
can feel the relationship deterring like
you just
you can feel yourself you know i'm about
to do something unfaithful oh yeah if
i'm about to oh gosh like god forbid but
if i'm about to do something unfaithful
which
yeah i'd i'd i'd leave like i would
never want to do that to someone john i
mean
okay so yeah if i leave but here's
as a man of principle
if i leave i'm not coming back
because
my my mindset is
what
took it so far that i couldn't have
worked hard to make sure we didn't break
up but what would you enter something
prematurely
wait uh all right if i
explain that how would i enter something
prematurely
you met a girl now yeah
and
maybe you're younger mm-hmm yeah okay
maybe it's because you're younger
you're now dating her and whatnot what
not and you're like oh
i would have known within the first
i'd say 15 seconds whether
i want to take her seriously or i
did this is a casual thing
just just to let you know
like
that's where i want to i would then find
out through character that maybe she's
not a serious candidate or maybe she is
but within the first 15 seconds i know
okay so there's no premature thing maybe
i amanda might be lying saying oh like
there is like i i couldn't tell i don't
know what it is they're lying they knew
exactly what it was from the jump they
know within 15 seconds the first
conversation whether they are feeling
you or whether this is a
yeah i'm just trying to smash and move
on so can i just
sure um
i feel like from this conversation and
previous conversation it feels like even
paul said that we are applying for role
as a wife
even though there can be women of high
value
even they
have to apply for the role so everything
revolves around the man
and
without the man
you can't do nothing because it's im
impossible to be independent
but
um it just feels like
if you're if you're a certain type of
way if you're modern whatever you want
to call it
then
you're not going to find a
i don't even want to say high value
because it's not necessarily just about
money because my
the definition of high value that i've
got is about money but for me obviously
the high value is something completely
different but then you guys would say
that's beta no